jetzt rufe ich auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt 26 Beratung des
Antrags der Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90
die Grüne und FDP mit dem Titel die
Deutsche Welle unterstützen und sie für
die Aufgaben der nächsten Jahre Stärken
der Sitzplatzwechsel hat schon
stattgefunden wie ich sehe es ist auch
genug Ruhe im Raum für die Aussprache
ist eine Dauer von 39 Minuten vereinbart
und wir eröffnen sie so hier geht es um
die Tätigkeit des auslandsenders also
für das Ausland Deutsche Welle der in
vielen Ländern der Welt zu empfangen ist
sowohl die Rechtsstaatlichkeit in vielen
Ländern zu unterstützen als auch über
Antisemitismus Antisemitismus Vorwürfe
gegen Mitarbeiterinnen der und
Mitarbeiter der arabischen Redaktion
noch mal Stellung zu nehmen
in dem Moment fehlt wissen und
JournalistInnen leben gefährlich und
Informiertheit war für Hannah Arendt ein
Weg zum Totalitarismus und Unterdrückung
folglich ist eine starke unabhängige
Presse die Voraussetzung für das
Funktionieren von Demokratie das galt
1974 und das gilt erst recht auch heute
Hannah Arendt setzte auf den einzelnen
Menschen auf seinen Willen wissen zu
wollen auf seine Fähigkeit selbst zu
denken auf Informationsfreiheit als
Bollwerk gegen Diktaturen aus genau
diesem Grund bekämpfen Diktaturen die
freie Presse Reporter ohne Grenzen
berichtet aktuell das so viele
JournalistInnen in Haft sind wie noch
niemals zuvor
533 inhaftierte JournalistInnen ist ein
neuer Negativrekord zwei Drittel sitzen
ohne Verfahren ein auf den traurigen
Spitzenplätzen stehen China
Myanmar und der Iran
Russland greift seit dem Angriff auf die
Menschen in der Ukraine zu immer
drakonischeren Strafen unabhängige
Medien werden von der russischen
Regierung mit größter Härte verfolgt die
freien Arbeiten nur noch im Untergrund
sie arbeiten weiter trotz der Bedrohung
der Journalist Ivan sapronov ist zu 22
Jahren Straflager verurteilt worden weil
er über Unfälle beim russischen Militär
geschrieben hat im Frühjahr 2022 wurde
die Deutsche Welle in Russland zum
ausländischen Agenten erklärt und
verboten ihre Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter folglich mit drakonischen
Strafen bedroht offiziell als eine
Reaktion auf den ausstrahlungsstopp des
russischen Fernsehkanals rt
tatsächlich wurde die Deutsche Welle
verboten weil Putins Regime die
Tatsachen über den kniffsverlauf mit
allen Mitteln unterdrücken muss die
Moskauer Büros der Deutschen Welle
wurden geschlossen den JournalistInnen
wurde die Akkreditierung entzogen die
Verbreitung des russischsprachigen
Programms der Deutschen Welle über
Satellit und alle anderen
Übertragungswege wurden verboten die
Reputation der Deutschen Welle und ihre
Bedeutung ist für das russische Regime
Anlass sie zu verfolgen denn ja die
Deutsche Welle ist ein wichtiger
globaler Player in der Medienwelt
geworden ihre Geschichte ist zweifellos
eine Erfolgsstory heute verfügt zu über
Redaktionen weltweit und sie sendet in
34 Sprachen wo sie arbeite trägt sie
entscheiden zu Diversifizierung des
Medienangebots bei besonders in Ländern
mit restriktiver staatlicher
Medienpolitik und gerade dort wo
Repression und Desinformation regieren
ist sie oft der einzige Fixstern für die
Pressefreiheit und die Fakten basierte
Weiterbildung dafür möchte ich den
Journalistinnen und Journalisten der
Deutschen Welle weltweit unsere
Hochachtung aussprechen
für die Zukunft hat die Deutsche Welle
viel vor sie wird der
Informationsangebot ausbauen so sieht es
die Aufgabenplanung bis 2025 vor
zwar der russischen Propaganda ihre
russischsprachigen Angebote
entgegensetzen und weiter ausbauen sie
wird sich technisch weiterentwickeln
digitaler werden und sich fit machen um
repressive technische Blockaden zu
überwinden stärker werden soll auch die
Deutsche Welle Akademie und das gerade
dort wo rechtsstaatliche Grundsätze
missachtet werden die Akademie soll zum
Zentrum internationaler
Medienentwicklung werden verstärkt aus-
im eigenen Haus muss die Deutsche Welle
einiges tun es geht darum die Zahl der
festangestellten zu erhöhen denn solide
berufliche Perspektiven sichern Qualität
und kritische Berichterstattung ein
wichtiges Thema bleibt dabei die weitere
Prüfung der antisemitischen Vorfälle in
der nahost-redaktion der Deutschen Welle
hier steht die gutachterliche Prüfung
noch aus bisher liegen bereits ein
Maßnahmenplan zur Bekämpfung von
Antisemitismus vor danach wurde der Code
of contact aktualisiert und
unterstrichen dass Diskriminierung die
Sexismus Rassismus und Antisemitismus
nicht toleriert wird das ist
entscheidend denn als der deutsche
Ausländer steht die Deutsche Welle
weltweit für die Werte unserer
freiheitlichen Demokratie
sie kooperiert dabei mit
mittlerorganisationen wie den
goetheinstituten und den deutschen
Auslandsschulen und das ist wichtig denn
angesichts der Tatsache dass der
Fachkräftemangel unseren
wohlstandgefährdeten angesichts der
Tatsache dass wir gerade für den Erhalt
unserer Wirtschaftskraft mehr
Zuwanderung brauchen kommt auch der
Deutschen Welle hier eine noch stärkere
Bedeutung zu denn die Einwanderung von
Arbeitskräften ist ein wichtiger
Baustein für ein modernes
Einwanderungsland umso wichtiger ist es
dass die Deutsche Welle ein aktuelles
realistisches Deutschlandbild vermittelt
dass sie ein Bild der Arbeitsrealität
vermittelt dass sie klare Einblicke gibt
in Sprache Kultur und leben in
Deutschland dass sie ein Bild unserer
freiheitlichen Demokratie vermittelt
dass sich durch eine Vielfalt von
Lebensentwürfen auszeichnet
Demokratie daran erinnert Hannah Arend
immer wieder will gelebt werden muss
gewollt werden und muss verteidigt
werden demokratie braucht mündige
BürgerInnen die eine Haltung haben eben
weil sie die freie Presse informiert
sind eine starke Stimme ist dabei die
Deutsche Welle die mit Ihrer Vorgaben
Vorhabenplanung auf der Höhe der Zeit
ist bedanke mich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
er hat Gründe von den bündnisgründen hat
es jetzt noch mal kurz zusammengefasst
und was es in dieser Debatte geht
nämlich dass die Deutsche Welle als
unser auslandsender eine Art Vehikel
auch für den Rechtsstaat Export der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland sein soll es
bildet ja die bundesgesellschaftlich
auch im Ausland an nächster Redner Marco
wanderwitz von der Unionsfraktion
alles das was Kollege Grundl ausgeführt
hat will ich zunächst einmal eins zu
eins unterschreiben und mir zur eigenen
machen und ich will auch auf dem Thema
Iran beginnen
am 14 dezember also vor zwei Tagen war
in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung
ein interessanter aber gleichwohl
erschütternder Artikel über die
Bedrängungen und Bedrohungen denen die
Journalistinnen und Journalisten im Iran
ausgesetzt sind unter dem Titel das
Regime verfolgt uns überall und frau
Präsidentin mit Ihrer Zustimmung würde
ich gerne einige Sätze aus diesem
Artikel zitieren
groß ist auch der Druck auf ausländische
Sender wie die Deutsche Welle die seit
über 60 Jahren auf Persisch berichtet
früher per Radio heute multimedial über
die Website Youtube oder soziale Medien
wie ein instagram-kanal mit 1,6
Millionen Followern die Angebote die
eine 40-köpfige Redaktion in Bonn und
Berlin produziert sind seit Beginn der
Proteste trotz Internet Blockade auf die
später noch kommen möchte
gefragt wie nie und das Regime reagiert
es wirft der Redaktion die Unterstützung
von Terroristen vor und schüchtert in
Iran lebende Freunde und die Familien
von Mitarbeitern des Senders ein wir
haben schon viel erlebt sagt die
Redaktionsleiterin aber noch nicht in
diesem
Ausmaß kann man Beispiele nennen eines
der bekanntesten Gesichter der Redaktion
will uns zumindest von den
Einschüchterungsversuchen erzählen die
er seit Beginn seiner Arbeit für die
Deutschen Welle vor einem Jahr erlebt
wobei er schon vorher bedroht worden sei
ich berichte seit vielen Jahren kritisch
über Themen wie die revolutionsgarten
oder Korruption das war nicht möglich
als ich noch im Iran lebte aber es wurde
möglich als ich ins Ausland ging die
Folgen bekam seine in der Heimat
verbliebenen Verwandten zu spüren sie
wurden als Reaktion auf einzelne
Beiträge und einen offenen Brief den er
mit 30 Regimekritikern unterzeichnete zu
den Sicherheitsbehörden zitiert man
befragte sie und bedrängte sie
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das was
die Journalistinnen und Journalisten der
Deutschen Welle wie auch viele ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen leisten ist
unheimlich wichtig und deswegen
sollten wir hier im Deutschen Bundestag
die heutige Gelegenheit der Debatte über
die Aufgabenplanung nutzen ihnen zu
danken Ihnen den Rücken zu stärken und
ihnen zuzurufen sie tun das auch in
unser aller Namen
[Applaus]
und nicht nur im Iran genauso in
Russland genauso in China genauso in all
den anderen Ländern die anders als wir
Europäer nicht in den oberen sondern in
den unteren Regionen der Liste der
Pressefreiheit die regelmäßig Reporter
ohne Grenzen und andere aufstellen sich
wiederfinden
und ich habe es vorhin schon
angesprochen es kam im Artikel schon mit
vor diese Länder versuchen natürlich die
freie Presse die Auslandspresse der
freien Welt insbesondere auch aus ihren
Kanälen rauszuhalten es gibt Zensur es
gibt Blockaden und diese Blockaden und
diese Zensur zu umgehen ist eine neue
wichtige Aufgabe der Deutschen Welle
geworden die sie mit Bravour meistert
aber die eine tägliche Herausforderung
ist und wo sie insbesondere auch in
enger Zusammenarbeit mit anderen
auslandsländern der freien Welt wie
beispielsweise der BBC oder der Voice of
America immer wieder herausgefordert ist
ihre Inhalte zugänglich zu machen und
die Inhalte werden ja gewünscht und
abgefragt von Millionen von Menschen die
eben keine Möglichkeit haben in ihrem
Land eine freie Berichterstattung zu
bekommen deswegen ist es wichtig dass
wir als Deutsche Bundestag die Deutsche
Welle auch an dieser Stelle so
ausstatten dass sie das leisten kann und
deswegen will ich noch einige wenige
Sätze zum Thema der Finanzen im Lichte
des Haushaltsjahres 2023 sagen
wenn man den Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel
liest dann ist er sehr ambitioniert auch
an dieser Stelle und ich denke wir
sollten uns dort gemeinsam vornehmen
dass das in 24 und folgenden
Haushaltsjahren dann auch im Haushalt
deutlicher zum Ausdruck kommt als das
jetzt in 23 der Fall war
die Deutsche Welle hat über die Jahre
immer Aufwüchse erlebt berechtigterweise
und dieses Jahr war es eben nur ein sehr
kleiner Schluck aus der Pulle mir ist
klar dass das nicht einfach ist in
Zeiten wie diesen aber an dieser Stelle
sollten wir künftig noch mal nachlegen
damit insbesondere auch das Thema freie
Mitarbeiter ein Stück weit besser gelöst
werden kann so wie das auch im Antrag
der Ampel ja abgebildet ist aber eben
explizit auch das Thema
derzeit so Umgebung vernünftig weiter
betrieben werden kann
ja Stichwort zensurumgehung Marco
wanderwitze darauf hingewiesen wie
wichtig Social Media Kanäle für die
Deutsche Welle sind da ja viele
despotische Staaten aus dieser Welt in
der die Deutsche Welle ja zu empfangen
ist
Teile des Internets aber auch den
normalen Radio und Fernsehen empfangen
blockiert haben nächster Redner ist
gelinter von der SPD-Fraktion der
Sprecher für Kultur und Medien zum Thema
Deutsche Welle
[Applaus]
auch ohne Regie schön sie sehen Frau
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
333 Demokratie ich möchte dass sie als
merken wenn sie sich gar nichts merken
von dieser Rede möge das aber hängen
bleiben als Assoziation mit der
Deutschen Welle sie werden es nachher
noch mitbekommen warum und ich sehe auch
Herr Limburg auf der Tribüne und Frau
Massen wird sich ja auch zugucken sie
dürfen das auch in der internen und
externen kommunizieren verwenden sie
müssen es aber nicht
wenn wir von der Deutschen Welle reden
ist es glaube ich wichtig sich mit zwei
Bildern und zwar Impressionen klar zu
machen welche Bedeutung sie hat
gegenwärtig befassen sich mehrere
Studien damit deutlich zu machen die
unterschiedlich mediale Kommunikation in
Russland und in der Ukraine läuft
russische Sender Propaganda hierarchisch
Verkündung von kriegsergebnissen und im
Vergleich dazu kreative natürlich
strategische Kommunikation aber
demokratisch partizipativ modern
westlich orientiert in der Ukraine das
heißt das freut natürlich die AFD die ja
sich bewährt hat als Unterstützung des
russischen Angriffskrieges sie sind ein
Grund warum wir dankbar sein können dass
es die Deutsche Welle gibt in die
Deutsche Welle ist sowas wie die gegen
these zu AFD und gut dass sie das ist
in dem aber gerade diese Weise deutlich
wird in der Ukraine mit Medien umzugehen
und gerade auch solche Medien wie die
Deutsche Welle haben zu wollen ein
Rundfunk ist deutlich welche Bedeutung
das für eine demokratische
Öffentlichkeit und partizipative
Gesellschaft hat ich bin noch ein
zweites Bild nehmen wir haben ja Anfang
schlechtes Gedächtnis und vergessen
viele in der Vergangenheit waren
deutsche Medien erst recht in der
NS-Zeit im Dritten Reich solche die den
Terror unterstützt und verkündeten die
für andere Länder damit verbunden war
dass es kriegsender waren die sogar im
Kaiserreich nach dem Prinzip
funktioniert in einem deutschen Wesen
sollen die Welt genesen ich glaube wir
können zutiefst dankbar sein und auch
mit Demut erfüllt dass sich das so
fundamental geändert hat und vergessen
mir das nicht dass die Deutsche Welle
eben genau ein Gegenentwurf dazu ist
dass sie ein vielfältiges
auch in seinen Brüchen gezeichnetes
Deutschland darstellt nicht
propagandistisch frei unabhängig als
Medium und dass sie zugleich auch nicht
erzieherisch auftritt sondern uns
deutlich macht wie vielfältig die Welt
ist wie unterschiedlich die Menschen das
ist uns nicht erlaubt sein darf
herablassen zu reagieren das ist eine
herausragende Leistung eben dieser
Deutschen Welle und wir sollten all
denjenigen die im backoff ist aber die
eben auch an der Freundliche
Journalismus tagtäglich dafür arbeiten
danken und das für ihn glaube ich auch
einen großen Ablauf
und der Umstand dass die von ihnen
teilweise gar nicht gehörten
Zwischenrufe der AFD die man mal
mitschreiben sollte alle so wütend sind
und so gehässig zeigt ja dass die
Deutsche Welle ihre Arbeit verdammt gut
macht das ist die größte Würdigung ihrer
Erfolge und ich wünsche mir dass sie
weiter so unnachgiebig sind denn der
Umstand das schon vor Beginn dieses
Angriffskrieges und er hat ja viel
früher beginnen wenn wir ehrlich sind
vor vielen Jahren in den ersten Stufen
das eben die JournalistInnen
Journalisten der Deutschen Welle
drangsaliert wurden und dass sie
trotzdem Wege gefunden haben und auch
neue Wege über andere Plattformen
denjenigen die tatsächlich in Russland
informiert werden wollen die sich nicht
mit diesem Regime abfinden die nicht wie
die AFD ticken sondern die Demokratie
wollen in diesem Land dass sie
denjenigen beistehen das ist pur
demokratisch und das zeigt wie
fundamental sich die Bundesrepublik von
den Zeiten davor unterscheidet und ein
Zeichen dafür ist die Existenz der
kommen wir jetzt zu dem Merkspruch nicht
nur für die AFD aber für uns alle drei
drei Demokratie und ich verdanke das dem
Konzept der Deutschen Welle selbst denn
sie hat sich zunächst einmal drei Ziele
gegeben nämlich erstens eine
reichweitensteigerung auf bis zu 400
Millionen nutzenden Kontakte bis 2025
zweitens eine Steigerung der Relevanz in
Bezug auf Adressaten und Zielgruppen und
drittens die Steigerung des Dialogs des
Formats Dialogs und sie hat dann
wiederum das operationalisiert in drei
Schwerpunkten nämlich in Bezug auf
regionale Kompetenz und Präsenz gerade
um Relevanz herzustellen und zweitens
mit einem klaren Akzent und eine klare
Entscheidung online ist denn heutige
Nutzergruppen weit über die Welt
brauchen 9 lineare Angebote und sie sind
gerade wichtig in Zeiten in denen die
Autokratien immer weiter wachsen und zum
Dritten in allen unseren Debatten auch
nicht zu Final Debatten über
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
effiziente nachhaltige Nutzung der
Ressourcen jetzt komme ich zum dritten
Dreier Schritt unsere Aufgabe wird jetzt
sein entsprechend dem Koalitionsvertrag
eben den Ausbau dieser Deutschen Welle
und der Deutschen Welle Akademie
erfolgreich und kontinuierlich
fortzusetzen es wird zweitens die
Aufgabe sein gerade wo jetzt die BBC
eben nicht mehr Stimmen Europas ist dazu
beigetragen beizutragen dass die
Deutsche Welle zusammen mit der
französischen Schwester genau das sein
kann ein solches europäisches narrativ
in einer multipolaren Welt mit einem
akuten dringenden systemwettbewerb und
drittens vergessen wir das nicht wir
wollen doch ein einmaliges leiden sein
jedenfalls vielen Teil dieser Parlament
ist will es nicht aber die meisten
wollen nicht und ein solches
Einwanderungsland das ja auch
EinwandererInnen und Einwanderer will
und Fachkräfte das braucht Brücken und
wer wenn ich die Deutsche Welle kann
eine solche Brücke sein und einen
solchen Kontakt herstellen danke Ihnen
bei der Deutschen Welle dass sie
Menschen unabhängig informieren mit
datenausstatten dass sie dafür sorgen
dass Menschen mündige BürgerInnen Bürger
sind und danke dass Sie jeden Tag ein
Stachel im Fleisch der AFD sind ich
danke Ihnen allen ich wünsche Ihnen eine
frohe Weihnachtszeit und vor allem bin
ich dankbar für die gemeinsame
parlamentarische Arbeit ich danke Ihnen
allen mit dem man konstruktiv
zusammenarbeitet und ich danke ihnen
weil sie mich täglich von rechts daran
erinnern warum ich gerne Politik mache
nämlich gegen sie vielen Dank
ja die Deutsche Welle als Stacheln
vielleicht der AFD das war jetzt schon
die Ankündigung des nächsten Redners
Martin Renner von der AFD
medienpolitische Sprecher möglicherweise
wird die atmosphärische atmosphärische
Spannung im Saal hier etwas steigen
[Musik]
sehr verehrtes Präsidium der vorliegende
Antrag der Koalition
lobt die Deutsche Welle als Schaufenster
und Leuchtturm unseres Landes in der
Welt
Schaufenster unseres Landes in der Welt
zu sein ja das wäre genau der
gesetzliche Auftrag der Deutschen Welle
in Wirklichkeit aber zeigt sich die
Deutsche Welle zunehmend als Mitsänger
im Chor der internationalen
kulturmassistischen wowismus Ideologie
ein Chor der getragen wird von links
grünen ökosozialistischen Regierungen
von internationalen politischen
Institutionen NGOs
Organisationen und Stiftungen und von
milliardenschweren angeblichen Fehlern
Tropen und gekauften beeinflussungs- und
agitationsblockflöten und dieser Chor
vermischt und punscht die
unterschiedlichen nationalstaatlichen
kulturellen Werte und Identitäten
zusammen aber meine Damen und Herren das
ist beileibe nicht kulturschaffend das
ist Kultur zerstörend
dieser globalistisch orchesterierte
baukasmus trompetet unendlich seine
angebliche moralische Überlegenheit in
alle Welt hinaus mit dem Anspruch des
Klima zu retten nein gleich die ganze
Welt zu retten um eine bessere Welt zu
schaffen mit besseren Weltbürgern diese
missionarische Eifer und diese
vermeintlich moralische Überlegenheit
ist nichts anderes als ein dominantes
herrschen wollendes Werte Imperialismus
habe es führt zu Bevormundung und zu
erzieherischen Beeinflussung Belehrung
der anderen und klar da ist dann oft
auch ein gehöriger Anteil
antisemitischer und antizionistische
Agitation und Propaganda im Orchesters
[Applaus]
sind doch die eigentlich uns
selbstverständlich die guten genau das
ist die Linie unserer linksgrünen
ökosozialistischen Regierung das ist der
Anspruch der EU das sind die Ziele der
globalistischen Bewegung und das soll
jetzt auch Aufgabe der opportunistisch
an diesem Kranken Zeitgeist orientierten
Deutschen Welle sein da schreibt die
Koalition doch allen Ernstes ich zitiere
sie die Deutsche Welle repräsentiert
Deutschland und wird für die Vielfalt
von Lebensentwürfen damit repräsentiert
die Deutsche Welle gewachsene
europäische Werte wenn das unser
Schaufenster in der Welt sein soll dann
gehört dieser Schaufenster gestaltende
Dekorateur dringend gefeuert doch es
kommt noch schlimmer der Deutsche Welle
soll mit diesem Antrag auch eine Blanco
Vollmacht zur aktivistischen
außenpolitischen Agitation und
Einflussnahme erteilt werden eine solche
Ermächtigung steht niemals der in den
Natur der Deutschen Welle zu es sei denn
sie handelt immerhin Absprache mit der
Regierung dann habe ich sie angebliche
staatsfire nicht das Papier werden auf
den diese staatszone behaupten wird
die Alternative für Deutschland liegen
diesen werde zerstörenden identitäts
vernichtenden und kollektivistischen
linken Zeitgeist entschieden ab die
Deutsche Welle der die gut daran zu
ihrem gesetzlichen Auftrag
zurückzufinden nämlich unser deutsche
Schaufenster in der Welt zu sein nicht
aber die missionarische Brechstange für
die Planung einer Gottlosen linksgrünen
kulturmarktsichtlichen Dystopie mit
einer erschreckenden und nicht
wünschenswerten Gesellschaftsordnung
friede sei mit euch und eine schöne
Weihnachtszeit danke schön
sagt Martin render von der AFD
medienpolitische Sprecher der Fraktion
hier im Bundestag in der FDP gibt es
diese Funktion auch das
medienpolitischen Sprechers sie hat
Thomas Hacker in der und der ist jetzt
am Rednerpult sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen vor wenigen Wochen hat das
iranische Außenministerium Sanktionen
gegen mehrere europäische Politiker und
Journalisten verhängt neben der
Bild-Zeitung war auch die fahrt ihr
Redaktion der Deutschen Welle betroffen
der Vorwurf lautet Unterstützung von
Terrorismus lieber Herr Limburg den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Redaktion
gilt unsere volle Solidarität machen sie
weiter und unterstützen Sie so den Weg
des iranischen Volkes in die Freiheit
wir stehen an ihrer Seite wir stehen an
der Seite des iranischen Volkes
die weltweiten Entwicklungen zeigen uns
gerade so eindrucksvoll warum die Arbeit
der Deutschen Welle so wichtig ist sie
ist das unverzichtbare
Informationsangebot dort wo unabhängige
Medien noch nicht oder nicht mehr
vorhanden sind sie ist das Fenster in
eine Welt jenseits von Unterdrückung
Angst und staatlicher Propaganda die
werden autoritären und totalitären
Systemen so oft erleben die Deutsche
Welle die im kommenden Jahr ihren 70
geburtstag feiern kann hat sich durch
seriösen Journalismus überzeugten der
reporterarbeit und absolute
Glaubwürdigkeit weltweit renomme
erarbeitet
289 Millionen wöchentliche
nutzerkontakte erreicht man gerade in
diesen Zeiten nicht durch Fake News und
filterblasen sondern im Beharren auf die
Grundsätze des Journalismus Aktualität
Faktizität und Relevanz
dieses Vertrauen bei den Menschen vor
Ort oder in der Diaspora wollen wir als
Ampel Regierungskoalition stärken und
unterstützen die vorgestellte
Aufgabenplanung 22 bis 25 ist nicht nur
die Reaktion auf das gewandelte
Mediennutzungsverhalten eine neue
Medienlandschaft und gesellschaftliche
Veränderungen sie unterliegt auch den
Herausforderungen einer Welt im Wandel
davor braucht es Vernetzung vor Ort in
der kulturelle Kompetenz und zugleich
die redaktionellen Voraussetzungen
diesen Herausforderungen auch gerecht
werden zu können dafür braucht es die
technische Voraussetzung Zensur und
repressive Blockaden auch umgehen zu
können
natürlich ist in einer weltweiten
Senderfamilie nicht alles perfekt
entscheidend ist jedoch dass man sich
Problemen verantwortungsvoll stellt
diese aufarbeitet und daraus lernt ein
professioneller Umgang mit den Problemen
Fällen seit dem vergangenen November
hätte nicht anders aussehen können aus
der aufrichtigen Aufarbeitung folgten
Konsequenzen auch darüber sprechen wir
heute und demnächst im Ausschuss bei der
Prävention von Antisemitismus muss die
Deutsche Welle auch externe Expertise
nutzen und die eingeleiteten
Veränderungen konsequent fortsetzen
wenn wir die Stärkung von
Meinungsfreiheit und Demokratie weltweit
ernst nehmen dann müssen wir vor allem
die Menschen vor Ort dazu befähigen
diese Werte auch selbst vermitteln zu
können die Arbeit der Deutschen Welle
Akademie als lernen fortbildungs-
Russlands Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
hat die Welt verändert und während die
aktuelle Lage in Russland und Belarus
die Arbeit der Deutschen Welle vor
erheblicher Schwert dürfen wir Sie
keinesfalls aufgeben ganz im Gegenteil
der Ausbau der russischsprachigen
Angebote im digitalen Raum ist
unverzichtbar wenn wir im Kampf gegen
Desinformation bestehen wollen den
angestrebten Aufbau von freien russisch
sprachlichen Medien und Medieninhalten
in Zusammenarbeit mit der Ukraine und
anderen europäischen Partnern können wir
als Deutscher Bundestag daher nur
entschieden begrüßen
Russlands und Chinas expansives globales
Handel macht es darüber hinaus notwendig
künftig gerade in Afrika und Asien
präsenter zu sein wenn nach dem jüngsten
militärputin Burkina Faso Demonstranten
russische Flaggen schwenken dann müssen
wir als freie Welt alarmiert sein wie
beschriebes Zeit online kürzlich zu
treffend
geht nach Südafrika Wagner dreht einen
Film über Zentralafrika und Diplomaten
machen Twitter Propaganda die
pro-russische Stimmung auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent ist kein Zufall
wenn wir mit Fakten gegen Fake News
bestehen wollen dann geht es in dieser
Zeit nicht im nationalen alle Eingang es
braucht eine Strategie medialer
Partnerschaften und gemeinsamer Angebote
eine Zusammenarbeit mit auslandshändern
unsere demokratischen Freunde ist
unabdingbar liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lassen Sie uns gemeinsam die
Deutsche Welle für die Aufgaben der
nächsten Jahre stärken und unterstützen
für unsere Demokratie für höhere
Freiheit vielen Dank
so jetzt kommt die
voraussichtlich tritt letzte Rednerin
ist es dort letzte Rednerin ist Petra
Sitte von den Linken Sprecherin für
Medien Politik
auf einer Sekunde verzichtet haben sehr
gut dr Petra
sind dafür die Fraktion Die Linke und es
gibt mit Katrin Göring-Eckardt auch
einen neuen neue amtierende
Bundestagspräsidentin
ist ja nun noch nicht so lange her dass
wir hier mehrfach über Pressefreiheit
und über die Deutsche Welle und ihre
Bedeutung gesprochen haben ich will
daher nur wenige Punkte in der mir
verbleibenden Zeit ansprechen erstens
die Debatten die wir in den letzten
Monaten zum öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk geführt haben sollten auch die
Deutsche Welle mit einschließen mithin
gibt es ja durchaus strukturelle
Parallelen Transparenz Aufsicht
Beteiligung müssen natürlich auch
Anspruch der Deutschen Welle sein dafür
sollten eben auch die jüngsten Skandale
beim öffentlich-rechtlichen
rundfunkanlass geben und natürlich auch
Impulse aufgenommen werden zweitens
insbesondere ist die Frage der
Unabhängigkeit der Deutschen Welle für
ihre Glaubwürdigkeit zentral insofern
ist nicht klar warum immer noch mit
zweierlei Maß gemessen wird so sollten
beispielsweise auch die Vorgaben des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts als Vorbild
für die Staatsferne der Aufsicht
genommen werden drittens eine Stärkung
der Deutschen Welle ist zu begrüßen ohne
wenn und aber angesichts weltweiter
angesichts weltweiter Bedrohung der
Pressefreiheit die Kollegen haben es
ausgeführt muss in der Tat ein
Schwerpunkt auf Länder und Regionen
gelegt werden in denen es eben keine
freie und vielfaltige Presse gibt dazu
gehört sehr wohl Bemühungen zur Umgehung
von Zensurmaßnahmen durch Diktatoren und
Autokraten auszuweiten und natürlich
müssen Mitarbeitende insbesondere im
Ausland dann besonders sensibel
geschützt werden und effektiv geschützt
werden damit sind schließlich viertens
auch die Mitarbeitenden der Deutschen
Welle angesprochen die ihr Angebot ja
erst schaffen diese brauchen gute
Arbeitsbedingungen und verlässliche
Beschäftigungsperspektiven
da steht die Bundesregierung als
Geldgeberin natürlich in besonderer
Verantwortung und schließlich meine
Damen und Herren müssen die
Mitarbeitenden die anstehenden
Entscheidungen zur Weiterentwicklung der
Deutschen Welle nicht nur mitwirken
können sondern mit bestimmen können und
ich habe gute also ich habe genügend
Anlass anzunehmen bei den Entwicklungen
und Darstellung die wir unlängst im
Ausschuss von den Vertreterinnen und
Vertretern der Deutschen Welle bekommen
haben dass das auch geschieht besten
Dank und frohe Weihnachten
Petra Sitte von den Linken mit ihrem
Redebeitrag die voraussichtlich
vorletzte Rednerin ist Katrin Butter von
der SPD katrin-fraktion
frau Präsidentin jetzt fühle ich mich
unter Druck gesetzt dass ich auch ein
Spaß frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren sehr Renner da war selbst der
schwarze Kanal mit Karl Eduard von
Schnitzler besser als sie in ihrer Rede
eben und das will man schon viel heißen
wenn man das schafft wann immer ich mit
dem Ausschuss für Kultur und Medien in
der Welt unterwegs bin oder für den
Ausschuss besuche ich die Kolleginnen
der Deutschen Welle vor Ort mal sind es
direkte Sendestationen der Deutschen
Welle mal sind es Kooperationspartner
der Deutschen Welle Akademie mal sind
das Projekte der Hannah Arendt
Initiative wir waren jetzt als Ausschuss
gerade wieder in Georgien vor Ort und
haben auch dort die Kolleginnen die
zusammenarbeiten getroffen und immer
treffe ich auf Hoch engagierte
gesellschaftspolitisch fette Menschen
deren Ziel eine gut recherchierte und
unabhängige Informationen der Menschen
in der Region ist
eine Region in die sie mit ihren
Sendungen ausstrahlen und manchmal sind
sie auch da vor Ort die einzigen
wirklichen unabhängigen Medien in der
Region und oft kämpfen sie zudem von
ihrem Standorten dann in demokratischen
Ländern aus gegen die Einflussnahme
durch von autokratischen staatsländern
oder Oligarchen finanzierte
Berichterstattung kämpfen gegen
Falschinformationen und Fake News und
das in den Sprachen die in diesen
Regionen auch verstanden werden dabei
geht es neben der Vermittlung der
deutschen Sprache und der Informationen
über deutsche Politik Kultur das
deutsche Alltagsleben über Wirtschaft
und Wissenschaft immer mehr aber auch
darum ein elementaren Baustein unserer
Demokratie unserer freien Gesellschaft
der Grundlage unseres Zusammenlebens und
auch unseres wirtschaftlichen Erfolges
nämlich die freie und unabhängige
Berichterstattung zu ermöglichen dies
muss längst nicht mehr nur und darf es
auch gar nicht mehr nur auf deutscher
Sprache sein in deutscher Sprache
erfolgen aber und auch das erfahre ich
Karneval in der Welt die Zusammenarbeit
der Deutschen Welle mit den deutschen
mittlerorganisationen die ist super und
deshalb setzt die Deutsche Welle auch
Ihren Auftrag in § 4 Absatz 3 das
Deutsche Welle Gesetzes hervorragend um
meine Damen und Herren alle Punkte in
dem ampelantrag sind wichtig und keiner
darf gering geschätzt werden und dennoch
will ich mich auf einige konzentrieren
auf die die helfen eine unabhängige
faktenbasierte Berichterstattung die
Meinungsfreiheit und die Bildung einer
eigenen Meinung auf Grundlage freier
Medienberichterstattung zu ermöglichen
ich bin aufgewachsen im Kalten Krieg ich
war selber aktiv in der friedlichen
Revolution ich habe die deutsche
Wiedervereinigung mit allen guten und
schwierigen Situationen mitgeliebt
erlebt ich habe die strukturbrüche in
Ostdeutschland erlebt und versucht
abzufangen ich habe neues aufgebaut und
nicht nur zugesehen als ein neues großes
Europa entstanden ist ein Europa mit
auch sehr viel inneren Unterschieden ich
war während der Finanzkrise politisch
aktiv den Zerfall des Kriegs und den
Krieg im ehemaligen Jugoslawien
miterlebt ich habe mit Bewunderung
beobachtet wie aus ehemaligen
sowjet-republiken eigenen unabhängige
Staaten wurden die Teil der EU geworden
sind oder ihren Weg in die EU suchen und
ich habe mit Strecken gesehen wie einige
von ihnen wieder Satelliten eines immer
autokratischer werden in Russlands
geworden sind ich habe mit Schrecken
gesehen wie der arabische Frühling in
eine Katastrophe mündete wir haben die
globale Pandemie erlebt und den Überfall
Russlands auf die Ukraine es herrscht
wieder Krieg in Europa
und ich habe aber auch nach all diesen
Veränderungen in den 30 Jahren noch nie
wieder so viel Autokratie und Diktatur
auf der Welt erlebt und Unfreiheit die
Welt von heute ist eben nicht mehr
einfach klar begreifbar da gibt es nicht
mehr hier böse da gut da gibt es nicht
mehr wie im Kalten Krieg hier
Kommunismus da Kapitalismus da gibt es
nicht mehr Osten und Westen sie ist
verdammt kompliziert differenziert und
auch beängstigend geworden auch für die
Menschen die auf dieser Welt leben und
da wird gerne mal zur vermeintlich
einfachen Antwort gegriffen werden Fake
News und anderes zur Wahrheit in einer
solchen Welt ist eine freie unabhängige
faktenbasierte presse-landschaft solch
eine Medienlandschaft extrem wichtig und
sie muss die Menschen überall auf der
Welt
in deren Sprache erreichen die Deutsche
Welle leistet hier ein unersetzbaren
Beitrag ich danke auch noch mal allen
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern auf
der Welt ich persönlich finde in der
Gegenwart diesen Auftrag sogar wichtiger
als das Vermitteln der deutschen Sprache
obwohl ich meine Sprache liebe es ist
verdammt wichtig starke mediale
Antworten zu finden und die zu
unterstützen die für Freiheit und
Selbstbestimmung kämpfen die Deutsche
Welle wird im nächsten Jahr 70 Jahre alt
und ist dabei immer jung geblieben
helfen wir als Parlamentarier dabei dass
sie so bleibt
ja auch ein fleißkärtigen für Katrin
Budde verabreicht von der
Bundestagspräsidentin sie will Zeit
einsparen hier wird also weniger reden
prämiert und nicht mehr letzter Redner
in der Debatte ist Michael Frieser von
der Unionsfraktion er ist wie die
meisten anderen
Rednerinnen und Redner dieser Debatte
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Kulturen
Medien-
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin nur kein
Druck auf die Redezeit sehr verehrte
Damen und Herren lieber Herr Limburg sie
haben jetzt glaube ich schon das
Wesentliche auch der Debatte des
übermitteln des Dankes und zwar nicht
nur in frohe weihnachtlicher Freude
sondern ganz ernst gemeint auch im
Jahresverlauf an die Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter und zwar alle nämlich
feste unfreie Sie wissen was ich meine
mitzuteilen viel herzlichen Dank an
dieser Stelle auch von uns noch mal als
Unionsfraktion liebe Kollegen von der
Ampel ja wir hatten uns fast gefreut als
Mann im Koalitionsvertrag ein sehr
ambitioniertes
planen ein sehr ambitioniertes
Aufwachsen der Deutschen Welle gelesen
hatte die Aufgabenplanung die vorgelegt
ist eben für den Zeitraum 22 bis 25 im
Hinblick auf Reichweiten Erweiterung auf
Dialog auf regionale Kompetenzen auf On
Demand Programm beeindruckend
allein die Balance zu den Mitteln die
fehlt nicht dass das jetzt überraschend
kommt die gesetzten Aufgaben müssen von
dem was sie wollten als sie den
Koalitionsvertrag schon formuliert haben
eigentlich wesentlich höher sein und sie
müssen vor allem höher sein weil wir im
Augenblick auf noch größere
Schwierigkeiten treffen wir haben sie
jetzt das öfteren gehört das Thema nicht
nur Reichweiten Verlust entgegenzutreten
durch Blockaden Grenzen überwinden neue
technischen Möglichkeiten gibt es auch
seltsamerweise für die Deutsche Welle
nicht ganz umsonst und deshalb muss man
sagen es muss irgendwann mal eine
gleiche Lauf zwischen der Frage was
wollen wir was erwarten wir uns und was
soll es dafür und darf es dafür an
Mittel geben dieser kleine Schluck aus
der Pille das ist euphemistisch
ausgedrückt der wird sicherlich an
dieser Stelle nicht reichen und die Frau
Staatsministerin
hat sich immer als Kämpferin auch für
die Deutsche Welle verstanden und
versteht sich glaube ich heute noch so
man muss nur sagen beim Kultur bei der
Presse-Mitteilung zum Kulturen
Medienetat sehr schön formuliert
übrigens muss man wirklich sagen kann
man lesen drei Seiten aber kein einziges
Mal die Deutsche Welle also in
vorweihnachtlichen Frieden Frau
Staatsministerin wer ist nicht schlecht
auch mal bei nächste Gelegenheit
deutlich zu machen dass man es will
Meinungsbildung heißt eben auch unter
Mauern und heißt eben auch dass man zu
den Aufgaben die man will zu den Zielen
die man weltweit umgesetzt sehen will
auch die Mittel unterfüttern muss allein
das funktioniert nicht Ich will sondern
eine Beispiel machen wir waren alle der
Meinung dass das Thema Ukrainisch
russisches Angebot nicht nur sprachlich
auch inhaltlich als Information extrem
wichtig ist allein die verstehtigung
dieses Programm ist allein die
Verstetigung dessen was wir gelernt
haben unter aus Zeitenwende Gründen
notwendig muss man sagen ist die Zeiten
wenn die jetzt abgeblasen oder ähnliches
nein auch dieses Programm lässt sich mit
den zur Verfügung gestellten Mitteln
leider Gottes so einfach nicht
verstetigen und nicht ausbauen also
deshalb liebe Kollegen man würde gern
dem Thema Aufgabenplanung unterstützend
beispringen aber es bedarf eben dazu
auch der Ernsthaftigkeit in Zahlen und
für die Geschichtsbücher will ich noch
sagen weil sie immer so gern die 16
Jahre bemühen also wenn sich die
Herrschaften bei rot-grüner Regierung
noch daran erinnern hat mal der Raubbau
damals zu 700 Stellen weniger bei der
Deutschen Welle geführt dann haben 16
Jahre mühsamste kleinteilige Aufgaben
Aufblühen aufwuchs es wieder ermöglicht
dass wir da sind wo wir sind ich will
nicht sagen das ist nicht auf dem Schirm
haben hat auch diese Etage gezeigt aber
es wird an dieser Stelle nicht reichen
nächstes Jahr fahren wir 70 Jahre
Deutsche Welle das wäre das Jahr in dem
man dann den Taten auch noch sagen kann
übrigens wir haben es angekündigt aber
jetzt im Jahr 2023 ist es dann zu weit
die Mitarbeitern der Deutschen Welle
alles Gute Ihnen alles Gute 42 Sekunden
frau Präsidentin vielen Dank
damit sind wir bei 88 und dann demnächst
spreche ich in Minuten aber zunächst
schließe ich die Aussprache danke auf
der Tribüne für den Besuch und
sage dass wir zur Abstimmung kommen
zunächst zum Antrag der Fraktion von SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP auf
Drucksache 43 52 mit dem Titel die
Deutsche Welle unterstützen und sie für
die Aufgaben der nächsten Jahre stärken
die oben genannten Einbringenden
Fraktionen wünschen Abstimmung in der
Sache die Fraktion der CDU CSU wünscht
Überweisung und zwar den Ausschuss für
Kultur und Medien wir stimmen nach
ständige Übung zuerst über den Antrag
auf Ausschuss Überweisung statt und ich
frage deshalb wer bestimmt für die
Überweisung
das ist die CDU CSU-Fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen die
AFD und die Linke damit ist die
Überweisung abgelehnt und wir kommen zur
Abstimmung über die Abstimmung jetzt
über den Antrag der Koalitionsfraktionen
zur Deutschen Welle
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen und
die Linke wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die cdu/csu und die AFD und die
Linke möchte was tun die Linke möchte
sich enthalten dann korrigieren wir das
danke an die schriftführerinnen die das
schon mitbekommen haben auch obwohl es
kurz vor der Weihnachtspause ist damit
ist der Antrag angenommen